[Music]
people often ask me just how dire I
think the state of free speech in
America really is in the last two weeks
I've spoken at several college campuses
in California Arizona and Texas as well
as attended a conference in Dallas
primarily focused on free speech from an
academic perspective I spoke to dozens
of professors who feel that the ability
to truly exchange ideas or even to
express unpopular opinions on their
campus is at a perilous crossroad the
University of Berkeley wants the home
for the free speech movement in this
country quite literally went up in
flames when Miley innopolis spoke there
people with fairly moderate opinions
like professor Jordan peterson and
historian charles murray are shouted
down by self righteous students on
college campuses all the time now and
Coulter was first barred by Berkeley and
then told she could only speak on a day
when students weren't actually having
class on campus these safe spaces and
trigger warnings concept designed to
protect feelings instead of dealing with
facts coupled with constant smearing of
any intellectual opponent as racist or
bigoted has birthed a generation who are
increasingly intolerant of tolerance I
should also be clear here it really is
one side who's being far more intolerant
on campuses these days just think for a
second if any college campus invited a
far-left Marxist or communist who wanted
to end capitalism and ultimately destroy
the United States there would be
virtually no outcry the Marxist and
communists would have their event with
maybe a couple curious people
challenging their ideas in the Q&A and
that would be it the absolute reverse is
happening all over the country when a
conservative or any non leftist speaker
are invited to college campuses ben
shapiro a friend and former guest of the
rubin report has been banned from DePaul
for sharing his brand a pretty
mainstream conservative thought Ann
taifa the self-proclaimed anti-fascist
who actually used fascist tactics to
silence their opponents and who also
happen to dress like Cobras soldier
from GI Joe issued a statement and
threatened to protest Portland State
University when Christina Hoff Sommers
Peter Bogosian and I spoke there
apparently at the last second they found
something more anti-gay and more
anti-woman right before we started so
they move their protest somewhere else
and of course as I always say and will
continue to say you have every right to
protest and use your speech to counter
someone else's speech what you don't
have is a right to silence someone by
using violence or intimidation this is
why I talk so much about self-censorship
and the chill effect around free speech
violence not only silences the speakers
of today but in essence it silences the
speakers of tomorrow who will quiet
themselves instead of dealing with the
protests and smears and everything else
that comes with being someone who thinks
outside of the group what's being stolen
from these college students is the
ability to learn how to think about
complex issues while in university so
that they can be equipped to engage with
a diverse set of ideas in the real world
and that diversity diversity of thought
is far more important than diversity of
immutable characteristics be it race
religion or sexuality last week I spoke
at the University of Arizona with my
friend and former guest Michael Shermer
it turned out that there was a trans
Holocaust denier in the crowd yes
apparently trans Holocaust deniers do
exist not only did we not silence her
but we opened up the floor for her to
ask us the first question when we did
the Q&A Michael the editor-in-chief of
skeptic magazine who specializes in
debunking conspiracy theories is an
expert in debunking Holocaust denial
myths and he answered her questions
clearly and with facts the students in
the room didn't attack her or kick her
out
despite her abhorrent beliefs it was
actually a beautiful moment which shows
why free speech is so important we
exercise our right to talk openly at a
public event which anyone was welcome to
join she then shared her ideas which
then we countered with better ideas
while I suspect Michael didn't change
her
mind on holocaust denial we put our
principles of free expression to the
test this open discussion with a wide
array of opinions is how you expand
knowledge and figure out what you
believe not by silencing shaming and
defaming your ideological opponent sadly
the true tolerance that we experienced
in that room that night is an increasing
rarity on college campuses these days I
know I don't have to sell you guys on
the lunacy that's happening at college
campuses you see it every day with the
language police telling people what
pronouns to use on the endless stream of
insane stories coming from America's
campuses showing how intolerant the
so-called tolerant side has become what
I'd like to focus on here for a second
is the creeping groupthink and
obfuscation around free thought and free
speech that is now creeping up into the
political s lon
just this week you may have seen new
Democratic National Committee Chairman
Tom Perez say that the DNC won't back
any politicians who are pro-choice well
I have no problem with the party having
a set of beliefs as a guideline for its
policies that's the whole point of a
party this type of intolerance to other
ideas even if they're incredibly
difficult topics like abortion set a
terrible precedent for the exchange of
ideas in a pluralistic society this
specific event isn't a direct threat to
free speech but it does go to the heart
of how intolerance by the left is
driving otherwise liberal people to the
center and even to the right or as the
left calls it the neo-nazi all right
white supremacist far-right the more
egregious assault on free speech in the
last couple days however was from the
former head of the DNC and one-time
presidential candidate Howard Dean Dean
is a progressive who at this point
really sums up why this ideology is not
truly for progression of freedom and
liberalism but for regression of them
after hearing that Ann Coulter was going
to be banned from Berkeley Dean claim
that Coulter's hate speech was not
protected by the First Amendment
well actually Howard it is a hundred
percent absolutely full stop
first off Dean uses the amorphous term
hate speech which sounds like something
but doesn't actually exist yes you can't
call for direct violence to a person or
a group that's a criminal offense but
you are allowed to say hateful and mean
things that's the very part of free
speech that we have to protect because
the definition of hate speech will just
keep expanding until it includes any
speech that fears ever so slightly away
from group think beyond Dean's confusion
about hate speech he also apparently
doesn't know what the First Amendment
actually is as I know you know the First
Amendment is about prohibiting the
government from making any laws
prohibiting free speech it has
absolutely nothing to do with the speech
of a private person or hate speech or
university d platforming a speaker if
you truly care about minorities college
Republicans I hate to tell you are a
minority at most universities and they
deserve to be heard from just like
anyone else who has been offered a
platform
sadly Dean is a progressive thought
leader while he seemingly has no idea
about the very Constitution our
political leaders are supposed to defend
with this in mind I still absolutely
believe the best way to beat the violent
tactics of an tyfa or the intellectually
challenged ideas of howard dean is to
counter them with better ideas
we shouldn't stoop to their level of
violence or try to take away their free
speech we should teach the ideas of
liberty freedom and true liberalism yes
they'll only scream louder than us or
act more hysterically but I believe our
game is a long one and our better ideas
will win if we actually put them into
practice with this in mind we're
continuing our partnership with learn
liberty this week and joining me is
Brandon Turner a professor of political
science at George Mason University
he's an expert in political theory with
extensive knowledge of the writings of
everyone from John Stuart Mill to Karl
Marx we're going to explore political
thinkers from all across the map to see
which ideas stand the test of time right
or left Democrat or Republican male or
female gay or straight everything
issues starts with our ability to
discuss it and figure out what we
believe if we can unite against the
forces that will silence us we may find
allies in places we never thought we
would joining me this week is a
professor of political theory at Clemson
University whose research interests
include focus on modern political
thought particularly the British origins
of liberalism Brandon Turner
welcome to the Rubin report thanks for
having me on is pleasure so when I was
doing research on you you sort of focus
on everything that I've been talking
about the last few years so I fully
expect this to be the best episode show
that we've ever done me too are you
ready yes all right so what I want to do
first is because you've got a great
breadth of knowledge
I just want to knock I'm going to name
some people okay and I want you to kind
of give me a little bio of them and why
we should care about these people and in
no particular order although the first
two of my personal favorite John Locke
what do we need to know about John Rock
and why is his writings and his thoughts
relevant to today right so I mean Locke
is often considered what we think of as
the father of the classical liberal
tradition father grandfather depending
on who you ask
so most famously in this particular
tradition he wrote the Second Treatise
of government so this was written in the
1680s at some point and the basic idea
behind the second treatise is that you
know we live in a world that has a law
of nature along nature that governs it
this law of nature's entitled in fact
obligates us to things like to labor the
production of private property it
obligates us to protect our natural
rights it obligates us to to consent to
form a government so in other words
government based on the consent of the
people all this all this good stuff but
the real kind of the crux of the Second
Treatise and why it remains such an
important document in why it became so
important in the 18th century is that
Locke provides I think the clearest
articulation of a right of rebellion or
a right of resistance so the last few
chapters in the second treatise really
actually I think the whole second
treatise is shot through with the eye
that should a government fail to protect
our rights or furthermore should a
government actually become should a
government itself violate our rights we
are not only entitled to but actually we
have a kind of a duty a natural
obligation to resist that government and
to potentially violently resist it
so it's the Second Treatise that becomes
in many ways the the basis of the idea
is that that the Jefferson articulates
in the Declaration inspirational for the
French Revolution inspirational to for
anti-slavery thought in the 19th century
in America and elsewhere so if you look
at somebody like John Brown somebody
like Frederick Douglass I mean Brown in
particular articulated his case for
slave rebellion for widespread slave
revolt he articulated in the language of
Lockean natural rights so I mean that's
why I Locke's important in liberal
tradition he in some sense gives us the
framework for liberalism as a system of
natural rights and duties yeah so if we
were to look at 2017 and we see you know
hashtag the resistance and all of these
people that are that are really against
Trump I think some with legitimate
criticisms I think a lot of it as I say
every week is sort of just kind of
hysteria and an inability to accept the
election all that but the tradition of
just sort of fighting against the
government that in and of itself is
pretty healthy right I'm not talking
about burning the whole thing down and
all that but that end of itself of just
standing up for what you believe and all
that yeah me I mean it has it has a kind
of mix it has there's it's a mixed bag
in some sense on the one hand there are
these great historical moments again I
would I would say that the the 19th
century abolitionist movement would be
an example of it you've even see echoes
of this in the black power movements and
Black Panthers and all that kind of
stuff who insist on being armed at all
times if you look at John Brown's burger
with John Brown he's actually he
actually he created and he carried
around within this document would been a
new constitution for a new state in the
image of John Brown and he in in that
Constitution actually one of the
requirements is that both men and women
would be not required but encouraged to
go about openly armed at all times and
the assumption is that if you don't
present yourself as a kind of as a
potential threat if you don't say
listen don't push me around right don't
tread on me as it were yeah because if
you do I'm gonna I'm going to bite back
basically Brown feared and I think many
people in the tradition fear that I mean
tyranny is just going to be a net it's
just going to sort of slowly make its
way in right if you build if you don't
make it known that you're not going to
be pushed around there will come a time
when you'll be pushed around yeah do you
think we've kind of headed in that
direction because we sort of are and
it's why I do the show the way I do it
we become sort of just a dumbed-down
populace we don't realize what our
natural rights are and what natural laws
I mean it's a it's a stark doctrinal I
mean it's it it requires a lot actually
the the term that often gets bandied
about in this tradition is it's a kind
of a manly Liberty right so I don't know
I when I when I talk to my students
about this you know we'll run through
the lock and you know a lot of them
would be on board they'll tell me this
is you know this is great and I you know
that these are ideas that I was brought
up with in all those kind of stuff and
so I asked them you know quite pointedly
I say listen it's great that you're
enjoying this it's great that this is
that you feel inspired but it's but let
me ask you if tomorrow morning you woke
up and on Twitter or you found out that
Trump had suspended Congress he just
sent them home and you know he just you
know he decided that you know Congress's
had a good run no longer is useful he'll
be the voice of the people here on so we
just kind of send him home and maybe he
suspends the Supreme Court too and he
just says listen for a little while I'm
going to run things on my own you know
with the help of my staff or something
like that in that case I think everyone
recognized this as a gross violation of
right a number of different doctrines
and yet which one of you how many of you
are going to take up arms and walk up to
Washington and do something about it
there's respect that the number is
relatively few does anyone raise their
hand is a you get a couple of I mean you
know undoubtedly you might I do teach in
South Carolina go there a since there is
a certain tradition in these sorts of
things
so you get a couple hands but for the
most part I mean no I mean if there's
revolution is expensive I mean it has a
huge opportunity cost you might die
people have projects said things they
want to do so and actually if you read
the Second Treatise Locke's very aware
of I mean Locke lists all the reasons
why revolution is extremely rare
it's difficult to get the people riled
up to the point where they're actually
willing to take up on to defend
themselves
yeah do you think that right now we're
all sort of strange precipice where
there's a certain percentage of people
who have this distrust of Trump or think
that he's illegitimate or whatever or
Russia or all that stuff and then
there's another percentage of people who
think that our security services and the
NSA and FBI and CIA that they've all
become politicized now so in a weird way
we have two parallel movements that are
both sort of fighting the system I'm not
even sure which one I think is better or
more legit yeah I mean it so it the
question of legitimacy is a very tricky
one no I mean I would I would say this
that despite all the rhetoric and we see
this rhetoric all that I mean you turn
on Twitter not just the people with the
blue checks I mean you know not this
doesn't mention at all the people who
come in other people to blue checks yeah
but even the you know the kind of
rhetoric coming out of I guess
respectable opinion aiders all kind of
stuff I mean really the question of
legitimacy is coming up more and more
and it has previously and so it's the
question of legitimacy is a very big
question so fundamentally different
question then right is the government
being run by people that I don't like is
the government headed in a direction
that I don't like do I find the
government some sense hostile of my
interests do I feel that economically I
could be doing better at the government
grahamaway these are those are also
these are old-school healthy right
things whether question talk about yeah
yeah therefore they might say the
political question we often the
questions of legitimacy are is something
else entirely so question of legitimacy
literally the power that's being used
over me is beyond this is power beyond
right mm-hmm it's it's at some level
fundamentally illegitimate and I may
need to and I may in fact be obligated
to violently resist this so I mean we do
it so in other words we have this kind
of rich American tradition of resistance
that goes back to the revolution right
men like Patrick Henry who you know
fought against a standing army
you know fought for local militias
because local militias would be more
useful in killing tyrants and all this
kind of stuff we have the second and we
in other words we have this kind of rich
liberal Republican tradition that says
listen some point you need to be able to
defend yourselves you need to be able to
to be a kind of a
an individual of force right there was
an individual capable of bearing this
manly conception of Liberty and yet on
the the kind of the underside of this
right is Waco and Ruby Ridge white
nationalist movements and all this kind
of stuff and and and and Oklahoma City
and so and it's a dangerous
it's a dangerous doctrine lock call
Dayton peculiar his peculiar doctrine it
is it's it's troubling once you really
kind of dig into it and you start to
question right what I mean ultimately if
individuals are the the arbiters of what
isn't is not legitimate then you know
who's to say you don't get some you know
individuals with bad judgment who sure
make bad calls on and also it seems like
if we ever rose up violently against the
government way we know the government
we've seen tanks on our own streets and
all these armored vehicles and cop you
know cops that look like soldiers in war
zones and all that kind of it almost
seems that even if it was a legitimate
reason to do it it could never end well
they were you know and then I guess
that's really the yeah that's the little
x-factor of this whole thing ya know so
this this is very interesting so it's
very interesting to me the way that that
bloc's doctrine in particular emerged at
a political moment or something like
armed resistance by you know a regular
and ready population could could be in
some sense effective so you know Locke's
writing during it you know during the
time of several failed plots to
assassinate monarchs the Rye House plot
of 1683 comes up a lot in this in this
capacity the Monmouth rebellion of 1685
but you know that was in the 17th
century and so today I mean you know the
the government as it were the government
and we're going to be for thing about
these terms has tools at its disposal
that are just beyond our wildest dreams
now there are obviously limits to their
capacity for destruction we see this in
places like Afghanistan and it elicits
of America if Appalachians are willing
to kind of hole up in in the holler and
you know and just kind of see how long
they can hold off I mean it could be a
potentially long protracted without but
but for the most part right think all
that the government playing with a stack
hand is
and so in other words I wonder how
healthy a language of legitimacy is
particularly when and this is the other
thing I mean that's Locke's writing in
the 1680s and this is before we had sort
of regular elections regular peaceful
transfer of power so in other words now
we don't have to if we don't like a
governor that we have we don't like a
president we like a congressman whatever
we can just like someone else vote next
time and I think so in other words
there's a kind of an outlet there
there's a pressure valve that gets
released every once in a while
mm-hmm which is why and the question of
legitimacy which is why if you focus if
you if you're focusing on something like
the establishment like it was a deep
state we see these terms want these are
permanent entities they're not going
away they're not susceptible to being
voted out of office right they seemed
was sort of wormed their way or entrench
themselves in our lives in ways that can
only be dealt with through some kind of
armed resistance and so that that to me
that makes it more troubling sort of
question right if you think that no
matter how many elections come and go
this particular interest this malevolent
interest will never leave then you might
be willing to take it once and that's
particularly interesting at the moment
because the phrase deep state nobody
said publicly you literally no I mean I
you hear the phrase that a drunk party
or something somebody opal itical
friends would say deep state this or
whatever now it's become mainstream that
that there are these vestiges in the
government that exist that are I mean
how real is that I mean now we're going
we're going slightly off track right
here but I Oh presenting someone out of
my realm of expertise here but I think
there's a couple of things going on so
on the one hand in the 20th century we
do get you know in America we get this
what you might call the science of
administration or the science of
bureaucracy so particularly in the first
half of the 20th century there was this
attached to the progressive move in
number of ways there was this idea that
in some sense the system's employable
organization that thrived in the 19th
century of kind of run their course now
we have at our disposal we have this new
thing called political science and we
have sociology and we have economics
right we have these new sciences of the
social sphere that can help us in some
sense gain
control over the just a chaotic mess
that can be life in a mass society and
you know we can make in other words we
make public like legible in some sense
we can make it controllable so we
establish you know huge federal
bureaucracy the explosion the size of
the executive branch is a it advances
this so we do have I mean when you teach
an educational you teach American
government you do basically have to
teach four branches of government you
know your traditional executive
legislative and judicial but then
there's the thing called the
administrative state or the
administrative entities this huge thing
employs massive numbers of people it
generates laws it adjudicates disputes
between parties to these laws in ways
that you actually would think it runs
are the kind of government so if you
look at the Federal Register for example
this huge body of law that's produced
primarily through these executives
bureaucracies and so you can think of
that as a kind of permanent sitting and
not particularly democratic state so
it's you know it works in some sense
that the through the powers of the
president but for the most part this is
a kind of a permanent bureaucracy
staffed by determinant bureaucratic
officers so there's that part of it
right and then when you when you take
that wouldn't take the kind of
bureaucratic administrative state and
you apply it to defense issues you
generate things like the NSA the kinds
of things that we did after in the wake
of 9/11 then you've got a kind of
different entity now you're talking
about mmmnot the CIA is been around for
a while the FBI has been around for a
while but now you're talking about a
massive entity which is not only not
transparent but you know very hostile
towards efforts to make it more and more
transparency yes is where Snowden comes
in right right and questionably
politicized at this point and yet like
the others and all that kind of stuff
and it will difficult even to tell to
what extent it's below sized I mean so
you know I know I know people who work
for some of these agencies may they seem
like very nice people they seem
genuinely dedicated to keeping America
safe and all those kind of stuff I don't
think they see themselves as
participating in a political project one
side or another but it's it's just it
really is difficult to tell particularly
today when if it turns out that there is
some you know Russian Trump connection
or something like that it will certainly
look like this kind of standing defense
apparatus in some sense
to the downfall of the sitting president
so I mean that in terms of precedence
right it rises like every president from
now I'm going to have to deal with a
kind of hostile permanent defense
bureaucratic apparatus I mean that I
think is that's a problem right so on
one hand if there was some connection
and that's what took him down right then
that would be viewed as good on the
other hand the idea that this
semi-secret thing that that transcends
administration's would be the very thing
that I think John Locke and many of
these other people would fight against
because they didn't want that they had a
giant monstrosity
nobody well if that's that's that's
that's true in a number of ways I mean
and it's true at least in the sense that
we can't check this power right now base
almost be kind of sort of power into
themselves and from now I mean I think
what you'll see eventually is a kind of
equilibrium between presidents in this
defense apparatus where you know the
funding you know will keep the spigot
open as it were in terms of funding and
leeway and getting you your you know
your warrants and all that kind of stuff
under the agreement that you know you
don't try to deal with jibt wiser
presidency right so in other words I
think if this happens with Trump on it
might be a probably the last time it
happens yeah but it is troubling I mean
this is this is it's not a particularly
democratic institution yeah and it's
also one of those things that I mean we
could spend five hours now just going
down that rabbit hole and seeing where
we get on the other side and I don't
know that we'd come up with anything
that did anyone anyone grant comfort
right so let's move on to some of these
other people uh probably my favorite
political thinker John Stuart Mill okay
talk to me about John so with no you
jump up a couple hundred years some you
know mill also English actually creators
accurate bureaucrat himself he worked at
East India Company his entire life Mills
most famous for his book on labrie which
I mean based on the themes of your of
your show is particularly apt text I
mean those kind of a funny liberal in a
number of ways he's not much of a rights
theorist he's definitely not a natural
rights theorist I mean he's validly
utilitarian so I mean he you know he
didn't the nonsense I'm still thing with
unskilled thing was Bentham's
description of natural
but nonetheless I mill is not going to
Mill is not going to justify a kind of
widespread resistance on the basis of
rental rights being violated all that
kind of stuff so for him liberty is
justified precisely to the extent that
it is to the long-term interests of
humankind something like that and so in
a lot of ways I mean liberty is
something that you sort of as a
civilization know what's there as a
people you sort of grow into you have to
grow to the point where the free
exchange of ideas will benefit you
broadly speaking and you talked about
this in the foreword on Liberty but just
generally in on Liberty on Liberty just
gives the case for why we ought to
tolerate and by tolerate I mean tolerate
like not to ignore someone but right
confront someone with ideas that we find
deeply offensive and deeply troubling
and yet nonetheless allow them to say
yeah I'm glad you made that distinction
of the word tolerance even has become
politicized these that's right I mean
there's tension there's apathy yeah we
tend to mistake the one one for the
other
I mean tolerance drinker like religious
tolerance when Locke was writing about
religious tolerance I mean the demands
were for this were high I mean it was a
demanding doctrine it says listen
there's your neighbor he might be
engaged in religious practices that you
think you know not only are they
condemning him to hell but they might
actually suck you down I mean that's
available
right today we're like oh you know this
guy that food and need that food and he
wears that dress and I'm just not gonna
picture said about it yeah but so Locke
would say listen not tolerate people
with offensive views for a couple
reasons so on the one hand it might just
be the case that they're right and were
wrong so we're the majority or 99% of
the of the popular opinion in this
particular issue and then you have this
one guy who won't shut up and insists
that were wrong well I mean this is the
Socrates case right I mean it might just
be the fact that he's actually right and
that we're going to be made better off
through interacting with him on this and
actually that's a pretty healthy way to
view someone I like that right that
you're intent that your opponents
intentions might be good Mike yeah yeah
I know you might be wrong that's right
you might be right which itself is a
very demanding very demanding doctrine
but so in but in that case it's clearly
justified to let him speak his mind
because
if you're remedied of an error of being
and along then you're made better often
so it's just the fine or it could be he
says it could be that the truth is may
be split between us so we we hold most
of the truth we the majority opinion we
we were mostly right but the other side
might be right in some different ways of
a or the truth might be somewhere in
between in which case we're going to
come to a better understanding of the
issue through a kind of interaction one
of them but the most interesting case
though for mill that he makes a non
liberty is what if the 1% is actually
wrong like objectively on what if we had
a machine that could tell us without a
percent certainty you guys are totally
right about this this person really is a
crackpot she has no idea what she's
talking about should we tolerate that
view and of course we can think of
parallels for this all over the place
and I mean show it's if I'm a Jewish
community in Skokie or whatever should I
allow Nazis to walk through my streets
in protest in all those kind of stuff I
mean we know not even as long we know
that anti-semitism is wrong we know all
these sorts of these are horrendous
views and and holds no place in polite
society all that kind of stuff so should
we prevent them from speaking out saying
online they'll says no even in that case
he actually made better off through
interacting with these particular views
you are you're you're given a chance for
your views on a particular matter to
become some sense more alive yeah to
become better and I see this all the
time so I mean when I teach when I teach
something like Locke or when I teach
mill or whatever to students today I
mean a lot of my students I mean these
are good 20 year old kids they have the
right views on most things
mm-hmm right they know that human beings
are should be treated equally and all
this kind of stuff but if you press just
the slightest bit right if you say why
should they be treated equally what's
what you know what sort of doctor
reviews based on is it based on a kind
of natural equality is it I mean in
other words once you start kind of
poking around the edges of this view you
know they kind of they tense up a little
bit they're not really sure in other
words they have the right views but they
don't know they don't know a lot of
right reasons so they don't really
remember why or how they came to these
particular views they hold them in a
kind of shallow or several hollows of
the way and so for Mill interacting with
someone who pushes you on these things
interacting with someone who genuinely
does hold wrong views give use gives you
the chance to reinvigorate your own
views on particular issues so that that
I mean that's the basic argument of on
Liberty so he basically gave the
original argument again safe spaces
really right I'm ready let's do this
right to do this and see what happens
that's right so I mean yeah I mean I
would mean there's some slight
differences right so in other words you
know I think he's saying tolerate views
interact with views I mean there is this
it's a very kind of positive vision of
what we're capable of doing through
dialogue and through discussion and I
think it's a conception of dialogue and
discussion and many people don't really
believe in anymore I mean I think very
very few people are willing to kind of
to to say I believe that genuinely
through dialogue we're all going to be
made better off yeah I think today more
more people are willing to say actually
I'm some people might be harmed by this
particular kind of dialogue or some
people might we're only just going to
encourage ourselves even more deeply
interviews that we already have so in
other words there is there's a sense in
which Mills view it's an empirical
doctrine right is subject to to testing
I mean it's we can say listen it doesn't
work or there's certain contexts in
which fighting like this actually makes
things worse Twitter I think that's a
good example of a place where I mean on
Twitter I am generally skeptical that
that a better that better views are
being arrived at I mean I think there
are certain there's certain things about
the context of Twitter that prevents
that kind of dialogue you're saying we
can't solve everything in 140 characters
you know you're telling me oh yeah that
was John do you know what a fit I think
I think we make it worse a live because
I mean on the air on Twitter there's no
like you don't interact with people on
Twitter right you interact with
strangers and something you interact
with objects so like so you're on
Twitter and you post something in smiles
you know puts a nasty snarky comment
you're like well that's just another
whatever right another sjw or another
MRA or whatever yeah and so you don't
have there's no reason to engage them
you have a script and you're going to go
off that script mm-hmm they have a
script they're going to go off that
script we're just reenacting this I mean
it's almost like a game that we miss
like a video game yeah so you know
they're you know it's like it's a street
fighter game so they're going to choose
this character I'm going to choose this
character I know which combos work
against this
almost kind of stuff I mean I in that
case I think Twitter are almost
militates against a better understanding
higher understandings yeah and I feel
like that's happening across social
media although Twitter is a particularly
good example because it's a constant
snark battle and it seems like what's
happening everywhere you even if you
look at your Facebook feed where as I
talked about all the time I mean people
defriend people for having an alternate
opinion or somehow you're now bigoted
you know your mom's a bigot separately
you know and although they're all found
things about our grandmother's that
didn't want it out that nobody wanted to
know so part of this is just we're
entering a strange phase just because of
Technology because really the most
important thing is to do this as it is
what they had the luxury right that's
right I mean it's I mean there's a sense
in which I mean argument what argument a
particularly an argument fits into the
liberal tradition it does require a
particular context so I mean it requires
an engagement with a require so you
might say an engagement with a subject
if you don't think that the other person
is capable of changing their mind if you
don't think that you yourself are
capable of change in your mind in other
words if you don't think that the other
person is anything other than the
product of an ideology the product of
class position the product of their
gender the product of whatever it
happens to be but it was really kind of
pointless to argue with them right I
mean you're just I mean you're it's like
trying to get a Mac to run a PC program
or something like that it's just not
going to happen the hardware isn't there
so if you don't regard your interlocutor
as a subject in some sense as someone
who is capable of changing in mine or
someone who is capable of entertaining
different ideas of someone who is
capable in other words of what we would
think of traditionally in very
traditional offenses being rational
being susceptible to reasons then I mean
it's we do have to wonder like what it
is that we're doing right isn't that
cruel bigotry it well it is right so I
think Woollett so it's interesting I'm
not sure I wouldn't go so far as to
called bigotry I would say that there is
that we're encouraged to think about
people in these ways in a number of
different from a number of different
directions so you see that something
like this in that in what we think is
traditionally the Marxist tradition so
in the Marxist tradition we are all of
us we are you know consciousnesses that
are formed by our position
the class struggle so the idea is in our
head all of our ideas our ideas about
religion our ideas about sex about
marriage about children about work about
all this kind of stuff these are
determined by our position within a
class structure so when we tell someone
oh you're being very bourgeois this is
exactly what we mean we mean that you
are right you are very much a product of
your economic position I would say so in
that case right we do have to wonder
like if it's the case and I have just
merely write the the outcome of a
process that's already been
predetermined right in what sense am I
really engaged in a dialogue so we in
other words we said we see that position
on and some camps on on the Left we see
it too on the right so in other words if
I there's there's an affinity for
example in libertarian circles for
evolutionary psychology I'm lunar
biology and I'm not crazy about this for
very similar reasons right so the
emphasis on signaling and all this kind
of stuff
it says listen when I'm engaged in
argument I'm not actually engaged in re
but I'm actually trying to convince you
of anything I'm not treating you as a
subject and on myself in them such a
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
improve my position in in a hierarchy
and so I will use whatever tools I have
at my disposal whether it be moral
outrage whatever kind of strong signals
I can send to other people around me
that indicate in some sense my
superiority yes for you this is we see a
ton of this yeah we do so in other words
innovator and I think encourages that
kind of B that bi behavior but both
lenses though I think the Marxist lens
any evolutionary psychology lens I think
it discourages us from treating other
people as again if subjects is saying
listen I don't care what class you're
from I don't care you know what your
position is in the in the evolutionary
structure or something like that I think
that you're capable of being persuaded I
think your people have me in
conversation and I'm willing to sit down
and talk these things talk to you things
over so I mean I think it's we have in
other words we have a lot of tools at
our disposal these days for writing off
everything that we see around us for
reinforcing our views of our own
rightness yeah and on up there on both
sides of the political spectrum and I
think the word that we're well-suited to
identifying and distancing ourselves and
those yeah okay yeah we could keep going
there right sorry let's look Alex de
Tocqueville so a 19th century French
thinker I mean we
tocqueville and American political
thought courses but he's actually French
and is actually in many ways his
concerns were very French so I mean his
primary work is master work as the
two-volume democracy in America which he
wrote after having a kind of extended
stay and extended tour of America so
there's a lot of great stuff in there
there's a lot of great stuff about
American associational life the way that
Americans they practice unique form of
democratic liberty in that list they're
you know the organized new small town
but the small towns themselves are
really in some sense their communities
in their active communities so if they
need a bridge built if they need a
church build whatever it happens to be
they get together they say we're all
there are you know we we we are the
people that are capable of doing this
we're you know there's no one coming to
help us we can't apply for a blockade
grant or something like that right we
want to build the church we're going to
do it and so they build up what Robert
Putnam later called a form of social
capital and they lived free in essence
and Tocqueville is very enthusiastic
about this about the way that Americans
are organized in this way but for the
most part what democracy in America is
is that the kind of --all I mean what
the way I see it is it's kind of a long
meditation on what you might call the
fact of democracy so Tocqueville himself
had a kind of aristocratic background
his concerns you might say were
aristocrats in nature he was interested
in some sense diagnosing and coming to
understand this great new sweep this uh
this kind of distorted I think in the
opening he compares it to a kind of a
river that's flowing through the West
right that all these these old
aristocracy is this old way of living
this is beings were washed away and in
its place is coming this new thing
democracy by which he means you know
voluntariness um you mean the number of
different things and so he's just got
all these interesting chapters on the
effective democracy on things like on
marriage on family size there's a
chapter on the the effect that democracy
and democratic norms have on the size of
headstones
for when when people die and things like
that so in other words me probably how
big should they be and they felt exactly
how big they'll be and I mean all the
things so for him in many ways it's a
kind of a sociological critique of what
democracy is going to mean for our
political institutions with
mean for individual liberty what is
going to mean for some I mean I think
really what he's worried about is some
sense of national greatness in other
words and for him the Americans did it
right and he worried very much that the
French did it incorrectly but it it
wrongly and that they're gonna pay for
it down the line yeah do you think that
if he was here today he might think that
America has actually started to do it
wrong so can you talk about it yeah
Liberty and things of that nature it
does seem like we might be going more
the French ruin certain yeah so I mean
in the second book in particular he has
a lot of talk about what he called soft
despotism and thought that petition is
something that that worried him that he
thought would be a kind of a something
that was uniquely well-suited to a
democratic country and so what's the
basic idea of soft despotism is like
listen art is a democracy going to
accept some you know a tyrant who comes
in and makes some work long hours and
develops kind of stuff no he's not
they're not going to accept that they're
not gonna accept a kind of traditional
form of tyrant right who just you know
enriches themselves at the public
expense all kind of stuff what they're
going to accept is this off is a soft
despot it definitely comes in and says
listen you don't need to you know to
build your own bridges for example you
don't need to provide for the poor in
your own communities I'll do all this
stuff for you right I will we can just
kind of centralize this sort of thing
I'll take care of it it's much more
efficient if I do it anyway I'll take a
lot of this kind of responsibility off
your hands and for Tocqueville this he
worried that this would have a kind of
innervating effect on people that
instead of going out and building that
bridge or building that that church or
whatever it happens instead of going out
interacting with each other in
communities building up trusts solving
problems together in a local way that we
would instead right if we want to build
a bridge we might come together long
enough to fill out an application for
federal greater than send it on right so
Bailey we outsource the very things that
make us a community sorted that's a
that's a that's a really good way of
putting it actually yeah so that I think
is his fear is that we've you know
advocated basically these powers the
powers of self-government
we've said listen we don't we're tired
of governing ourselves in some sense
these are some of these decisions or
their great responsibilities some of
these decisions we don't particularly
like anyway we don't like making and so
we'll just sort of hand them over and
and live in a in a in a softer and more
comfortable sort of play
yeah for the people watching that would
say well what's the problem with that
why is that a problem well wait was it
what's the problem right I mean there's
a sense it's an active question I mean
there is that is an open question I
think right so it's no question term so
today you know we we've got these
amazing TVs and we got these amazing
video games and we've got to be amazing
everything and there is a certain sense
in which listen if if if what we are
building in the future is this kind of
what we in philosophy would call a kind
of heat on machine right so we just kind
of plug ourselves into a pleasure
machine
what's wrong with a pleasure machine
like what's wrong with just being happy
all the time particularly if these more
sort of rugged individuals kind of
decisions if you know these
responsibilities are in some sense
unhappy responsibilities I don't want to
have to build this bridge but I you know
I got other things I want to do I've got
a job I got kids I've got video games I
want to watch the NBA whatever it is I
want to do I don't want to go out and
build this bridge so in other words
what's wrong with just being as happy as
we can be and if happiness means and the
way you phrase it outsourcing these
responsibilities and then what's wrong
with them well I did see wall-e the
Disney movie wall-e and I know if you
outsource all those things you become
just basically a fat blob I you know
drinking soda and right over did you do
research on me because you've mentioned
video games of basketball and I think
you're just over here in the dressing
room there was a there was an old-school
NES sitting on yeah how are your skills
by the way on the NES yeah they're
pretty good actually what depends on the
game sports game I can do sports game
alright we got 15 minutes ago after this
maybe maybe we'll stream it to the
people alright we touched on this guy
already but I think this is probably the
person that I think is most confused in
modern discussion Carl Marx and when
people talk about Marxism I feel like
they have no idea what they're talking
about and especially as you mentioned
conversation on Twitter can often be
crazy you see this old people calling
each other Marxists and
our visit they've no idea what they're
saying so let's go back yeah yeah so
it's a huge topic I mean so I mean you
could you could spit your entire
academic career or your I mean you try
your life going through going through
Marxist thought I mean itself it's
contained in these huge volumes so
capital is great work that was only
Volume one of what we came three volumes
which itself was only 1/8 that's kind of
broader project that he thought is
working on please and you can't get that
all at one point well there are there
are days when I wish that Marx would
have just had a bitter end yeah which is
I listen I have to I have 3,000 pages
but I can break it down into one thread
on Twitter yeah and that's just one work
I mean hit the ears were unbelievably
productive remarkably productive over
the course of his life now we leave
Mandy about the term Marx today in in
strange way so I mean somebody like
Bernie Sanders right people are talking
my democratic socialism we love throwing
out these polls to Millennials and
saying do you like apples and dealing
socialism and when we act surprised when
they say socially well if their
interaction with socialism is something
like what Bernie Sanders is offering
there's nothing terribly socialistic or
Marxist about what what what Bernie is
is about so I mean Bernie is a fairly
old-school redistributionist does Burt
does Bernie Sanders want to destroy the
state no does Bernie Sanders want to
destroy the institution of private
property no Bernie Sanders just wants to
in many ways actually wants to reinforce
the state he wants to use the state to
redistribute wealth from those who have
too much to those who have less yeah I
think you can have all legit criticisms
with that but that's not destroying this
day that's an interesting distinction
it's not destroying to say that's
actually tightening the rightness Cruz's
no I mean it there's I mean any curse of
the distinction that has to be made when
we when we talk about the left and we
use the capital L we tend to conflate
many many different attitudes political
attitudes economic attitudes and so you
know in terms of textbook definitions
when we think of social when we think of
public ownership of the means of
production so factory or so worker owned
factories but also just industries being
run in what we think of as the public
service or something like that or to to
public ends and then full-scale
communism is the complete abolition of
private property none of those things
are think are really on the table
means I think in his younger days
Sanders talk about nationalizing banks
or something like but I mean for the
most part it's pretty tame I mean you if
you look at Venezuela you look at Chavez
you look at things like that I mean
that's what socialism looks like I mean
this is this is these people are more
serious social in the Capital Area
Bernie just
I mean he's peddling a kind of welfarism
whatever you want to call it but I
always see people saying that you can't
look at Venezuela because it doesn't
give you the right example of social
yeah the socialist only say that didn't
work out the way they wanted it to yeah
I don't know I mean the 20th century is
a pretty long advertisement but we think
of it I mean a lot of that head stuff
has to be teased down so I mean we have
a very difficult time of separating we
make thing as political or economic
philosophy from the rise of the
nation-state
the development of large-scale states
and all that kind of stuff and these
processes
they're absolutely intertwined but they
are distinct so I think in Russia I mean
a lot of the way you had was going on
there was absolutely this unbelievably
pernicious application of Marxism in a
variety of ways and I think a lot of
libertarian 20 century libertarian
thought offers good arguments as to why
socialism will always look like that so
in other words this wasn't an accident
right this is how it's always going to
play out and here are reasons for that
so if you look at me as if you look at
Hayek they make that case and those are
really good resources but at the same
time I mean the development of the
nation-state itself tends to be a fairly
bloody process particularly when we talk
about processes and modernization and
all those kind of stuff whether it be I
mean so if we think about World War two
right and on you know an unprecedented
Lee bloody conflict unprecedented bloody
event can we pin something on World War
two on marks I don't think reasonably we
can what can we pin it on I'm not really
sure I think a lot of these processes
are sort of broader mostly material
world historical processes that came to
that that came to fruition in a
particularly awful way when it comes to
money like mark I mean I think you know
there's a number of things so there's
Marx The Economist
so mark the Economist drew largely from
classical economics he readily read a
lot of Smith you read a ton of David
Ricardo James mill
all this kind of stuff and he attempted
to in some sense synthesize the great
political economists and he attempted to
I mean the way that I like to think
about what Marx was doing was he was
attempting to describe I mean he would
say dialectically I want to say that he
was attempting to describe the
experience of living in a commercial or
bourgeois society and so for me I think
what's most interesting I think the kind
of work of Marx is that liberals should
pay the most attention to classical what
famous men do if his thoughts on on what
it's like to live in a commercial
society on what it's like to work in a
commercial society we went to talks
about commodities for example in the
ways that we tend to organize our live
around commodities the ways that we tend
to commodify
many things in our lives but maybe don't
need to be maybe that ought not to be
commodified right he in other words
there's there's a kind of a built-in to
it there's a kind of almost an
existential critique of life within a
modern capitalist society that I think
there's no reason I think for classical
liberals to just say oh this is kind of
the Marx Marx was the marks of Marxism
Marxism is bad for these variety reasons
therefore we'll just throw everything
out together right I think with Marx I
think we can actually get a lot of
purchase or we can begin to understand a
lot of the cultural and artistic
critiques of capitalism that we've been
dealing with in the 20th and 21st
centuries hmm so basically you don't
have to buy the economic theories to
understand the critique of just sort of
the just sort of the human philosophical
tenants of it so so take something like
we take something like tender right
which he wrote a lot on tinder or
something they just wanted to spite us
the swipe that this well game right
Davis wiping one so there's a couple
ways of looking at tinder so one way of
looking at how you look at Henry say oh
this is awful are you say this is
something unnatural about this or
something just really messed up about
people swiping left to right treating
potential life partners essentially as I
mean the way you would look you know
look at fresh produce and this was bad
this one's good whatever I mean there's
something a little weird about that and
so you're you're put on the kind of a
horn to delimits you can either say
listen there's nothing weird about that
isn't it great that we can you know
conduct that we can lower the
opportunity call
dating or something like that listen in
the fact that people are doing the
suggest that it makes them happy and who
are you to say they shouldn't be happy
all I kind of think they're often kind
of thrown onto that side of it yeah this
is kind of whatever kind of commercial
behavior people adopt is good just by
virtue of them adopting that's that
pleasure machine you may that's right
anyway in other words we don't have a
positive role slack a really strong
footing to critique this kind of
behavior I mean we don't want any
anytime people critique other people's
behaviors and practices any time in
other people begin to rank different
ways of life we begin to think things
get a little thorny and we want to try
away with them so I away from that on
the other side is one is saying oh
there's something wrong about it
objectifies it objectifies number the
opposite sex or depending on up here
what whoever it is you're shopping for
right it objectifies them it does you
know it trivializes these meaningful
relationships it does this man all the
kind of stuff and all that stuff I think
is really powerful people people get
that I mean when people hear that it
moves them in some sense and I think we
cut ourselves off to all of these
methods of thinking about the way that
we live now because we're so intent on
keeping the economic side of things but
so we're because we're so intent
essentially on on denying that there's
anything wrong at all with any of the
behaviors in any of the practices and
adopted in in commercial society
so we're basically afraid to judge
because that would be against right our
sort of liberal position right I mean
still then puts us on a slippery slope I
mean this is and this is a very oldest
be within liberal spot right so this
actually goes back to the question of
toleration so I mean conservatives have
conservatives to have criticized will
boast for a very long time and precisely
because they treat apathy is toleration
because they mistake indifference for
toleration right you're not actually
tolerant of different ways of life
because you're completely and utterly
unable or unwilling to judge different
ways of life whereas I don't think
liberals are really committed to that I
mean using the coercive force of the
state to enforce certain ways of life I
mean that's one thing right right but
being able to have a conversation about
what sort of practices you want to adopt
what sort of practices you think your
children ought to adopt these sorts of
conversations in other words I mean we
kind of we kind of
we set ourselves off from the kind of
conversations about the nature of the
good life that communities used to have
I mean that people used to people used
to say you know listen I think this way
of life is better I think this way of
life is more meaningful I think what
you're doing here in this particular
case is is wrong I think it you know has
these effects and all this kind of stuff
I mean we really try to shy away from
that as much as we can and I'm not sure
that we're always better off for it
so that's a perfect segue I've got a
whole bunch other names okay let's put
that aside sure because I when you sat
down we immediately mentioned a couple
of other people that I've done some
shows with from learn liberty and Steve
Davies came up and I said to you that
when people probably number one thing
that I get asked is why do you call
yourself a classical liberal instead of
a libertarian and I've said a few times
that if I sat down probably with who
would you say is probably the most
preeminent libertarian thinker today
yeah just give me somebody alike yeah I
mean so I mean I mean online media tend
to be the economists who dominate this
conversation so Brian Kaplan who you had
on school weeks ago one's a very
successful blog Tyler Cowen I put in
that camp I mean so somebody like Jason
Brennan has gotten a lot of publicity
lately for his book against democracy so
I mean we were shifted out of I guess
what you might think of being the the
20th century libertarians Hayek and
Friedman and all these kind of guys and
we're moving into I guess a new
generation of a thought it intends to be
dominated I think by economists but not
necessarily so so the question that I
get is well what makes you a classical
liberal as opposed to a libertarian now
I sat here with Bryan Caplan a couple
weeks ago and he really in my opinion
goes really far on that libertarian
route right but I fully enjoyed the
conversation and I don't agree with you
necessarily on some passivism stuff and
some open border stuff and all that
that's all good
but I told you that ski Daviess gave me
the best explanation of classical
liberalism so I'm going to link people
to two things for now it can be P David
and whatever you're going to find right
now what what is the difference between
a classical liberal and a libertine
libertarian so I mean classical liberal
of them if I can get my students to
reproduce liberalism is the political
ideology of individual rights and
limited government if I can get them to
reproduce that I'm happy
that tends to be enough for me but how
is that different than liberty of
libertarianism also libertarianism is
relatively big tent so libertarianism
was in many ways it was a political
movement first as it were
libertarians include I mean Brian's an
anarchic capitalist I think yeah if we
talk about yeah here that sure or not so
it can go
the Brian capital day narco capitalists
I mean a variety of different sorts of
anti-state social it's all the way up to
Bill well since I mean it's a it's a
relatively big ten in essence in it's a
political movement that I think the idea
behind libertarianism seems to be
something like reducing both the size
and scope of the state so it's in some
sense it's a political project first in
it it tends to really want to resist
being attached to some larger moral or
cultural doctrine yes
liberalism I really do think that in
some sense liberalism was linked up to
some conception of the good life some
conception of rationality some
conception of a work ethic
all right so in other words what I think
classical liberalism extends a bit
further down as it were from the
political than libertarianism yeah in a
weird way if that's a flaw of both of
them that libertarianism became a
political party first so it maybe didn't
have the philosophical underpinnings of
classical liberalism classical
liberalism which was based in philosophy
first maybe doesn't have the route to
become a political party at least in
modern-day America yeah so does that
mean it that's depressing I yeah that's
an interesting question I would say this
I mean so when we talk about classical
liberalism I mean this is this is the
kind of the this is a function of the
way that we talk about ideology so in
other words you look at Locke you look
at Hume you look at Smith none of these
guys even as they produce the liberal
tradition none of them knew they were
liberals right so in other words we we
look back we said the the the set of
ideas the doctrines that were produced
by this generals set of thinkers this
Canon we'll call it full set the lines
here with anyone within this this way of
thinking we'll we'll call it liberalism
and there's there's many ways in which I
mean see take even people was con
illogically close to one another as
locking you mm-hmm disobey I mean they
disagree very
a number of different things so right so
humans not a natural rights there's the
Hume is extremely shy on the right of
resistance and all this kind of stuff
and yet I think we would would say that
both of them contributed to something
but looking back we call the liberal the
liberal project so liberalism I think
tends to be much much broader much much
bigger than the libertarianism I mean I
would say that today both major
political parties about 10 years ago was
that both major political parties in
America would fit within the tradition
of liberalism broadly understood though
I mean very few people are running
around today saying we ought to suspend
you know rights of due process you know
we ought to suspend free speech or
something like that very few people are
offering what I would consider to be
real alternatives to liberalism whatever
then whatever those alternatives might
be they might be theocracy they might be
communism I mean that's in other words
we seem to have and something settled on
the idea that individuals have claims
against the state that individuals ought
to be as free as possible and all those
kind of stuff and Sooey many ways we're
kind of working out on the margins of
that of that particular of that
particular view libertarian is who seems
to me as a kind of a smaller political
doctrine within that broader thing that
we call liberalism yeah it almost seems
to me that it's the classical liberals
which I do think are the next political
movement here we should just hijack the
libertarian party I mean it's such a
freaking mess yeah why not just grab
this thing at least they have some of
the institutional mind uh frightened and
grab that go who would you say are the
in American political history the
politicians that have been closest to
real classical liberals I think the to
the probably pop to mind for me would be
JFK and and New York State Senator
Patrick Moynihan and probably the most -
who else might or do you even agree with
those right I mean in a liberal
tradition I mean so general I would say
you know the I mean the founding period
these guys I mean somebody like
Jefferson - del slavery because I'm
Jefferson at least are thought he was
freeing the slaves at the same place
when he least I'll put it this way I
mean he articulated the ideas that would
absolutely be seized upon by somebody
like Frederick Douglas and Frederick dog
saying listen you know in his this great
speech he gives what to the slave as the
4th of July where he says your founding
documents are great they're beautiful
and yet at the same time what could be
further than reality than your founding
documents so in other words I mean I
would say that just generally men men
like Madison and Jefferson these not
only were they consistent with what we
think of the classical or tradition but
in many ways they contributed to
classical the classical liberal project
in the in the 20th and 21st century that
that's a tougher question so I always
thought that so I'm actually I'm I grew
up in a town called Marion Ohio and in
Marion Ohio we we have the warren g
harding presidential home ii actually he
ran the marion stars newspaper in town I
gave towards there for years but
Harding's idea of normalcy so Harding
was president after Woodrow Wilson
people forget that the Wilson presidency
was I mean I guess we were reminded of
this every once in a while but it was an
absolute mess we're talking I mean just
unbelievable American casualties and a
completely pointless war economic
catastrophe of a number of cents and
Harding actually ran on what he called
missus actually where we get the word
normalcy the return to normalcy and so
the he was only president for a couple
years he died in office I mean it wasn't
it was a great president by any ones by
any stretch of imagination but just the
idea of a restrained role of the
presidency the president as a kind of a
steady hand on institutions that I think
is relatively consistent with the
liberal tradition I think for me a
president for me a president becomes a
threat to the liberal tradition when
they see themselves as leading some kind
of movement as being in charge of a
vision as speaking for the people and
some meaningful sense this is very much
what the Progressive Era was about so
you see this in TR you see this in
Wilson the idea of the president being
in a kind of strange sort of way the
president in being a single person
popularly elected the president can then
be the kind of the voice of the people
and the president can you know carry the
big stick needed to deal with the
entrenched interests in the entrenched
interests in entrance interests in
Congress and big business and all that
kind of stuff I mean this was the
progressive vision I think you see you
see a lot of that rhetoric today on both
both with Trump and that also with
Sanders yeah so Trump though is a
particularly interesting case is right
because he obviously is that
things he's the guy in the populace and
all that and at the same time he doesn't
care about the social issues so there's
a nice classical liberal feeling of live
and let live there
he's trying I think you know even this
regulation thing where he's going to
strike down two regulations for everyone
knew it
it's gimmicky it sounds like a game show
right but what there is a nice scaling
back of the stamp there it doesn't sound
like we're going to have a lot of
adventurous war all of these things that
I think are basically within the
tradition of classical liberalism but he
has that other piece so how do you how
do you get him so no one I think has a
good rightful holistic understanding of
the game well maybe and I mean cuz in a
lot of ways he's there's very little of
him there right I mean he's mean the
classic line what Trump believes whoever
the last person he talked to you know
what that last persuaded him and I think
a lot of that is true I don't think he
has he doesn't seem to be terribly
ideological figure um I mean he he in
some sense intuitively grasped in a way
that a lot of demagogues historically
have he intuitively grasped in some
sense what whatever you want to call the
people I mean was a very particular set
of people and we're talking about Rust
Belt Appalachian voters I mean the real
red states also I guess out west
intuitively grasped what it was that
they wanted what they wanted to hear and
a lot of us didn't have anything to do
with policy positions a lot of it was
just you know listen these establishment
types have been screwing you over for
however long and I'm going to be the one
who comes up here and it does something
about it I mean it was the ultimate
outsider in an age of outsiders I mean
there is something a little tiresome
about this constant you know we need
Outsiders and launching teaming
Outsiders and watching all those kind of
stuff but nobody did that quite as well
as as Trump did and I mean so just in
the places that I grew up in Ohio and
wow my family's in West Virginia I mean
I could almost immediately wants to
begin talking I could say that they're
going to love this mm-hmm
where they're kind of they're tired of
being looked down upon in all this all
this kind of thing now when it comes to
classical liberal tradition my own view
I think that Trump is an unmitigated
disaster from the classic liberal yeah
actually the regular I might say he said
well I think he's maybe done something
that we can sort of tolerate right but I
don't think has a political philosophy
no he well he doesn't have I don't think
he definitely doesn't have a kind of a
clearly articulated political philosophy
or political ideology
right but he's very good at symbols he
understands symbols quite well the wall
is a really good example I mean the wall
is not a policy position will it
actually curtail immigration I see no
reason to think that it will most
immigrants apparently come over on
planes they overstay visas they do a
number of different things yeah
will they have any effect in other words
on this on this on this thing
immigration even immigration itself
isn't really a policy question the
average person their view on immigration
is not informed by statistics I mean
they don't know that net immigration
from Mexico is negative they don't know
any of this kind of stuff you know it
isn't it there's it it isn't real to
them as a policy or as an empirical
question but they do understand insiders
and outsiders mm-hmm and they do
understand what the wall represents in
some way so the wall represents a
reaffirmation of the American identity
or the idea of America and in particular
it represents that reaffirmation
reaffirming the boundary between what is
American what isn't who is America and
who is is not I mean there's a reason we
don't put the ball on northern border I
mean it's in other words the race is
very clear but Trump grasped that
intuitively he knew what the wall would
mean at some level it doesn't matter if
the wall ever gets built for for Trump
the wall was that symbol then he needed
to brand I mean it was just a big
four-letter word that he could sear into
the brains of every American and it
worked it worked tremendously but it's a
really good example of the way that
Trump was able to seize on this language
in order to speak this language without
any of the other sort of stuff that you
would think would matter I mean you know
Hillary Clinton had policy positions out
the wazoo but I mean nobody wants widows
yeah but nobody cares we can probably a
function of Technology and attention
spans and all the rest of it I think a
part of it is I mean I mean part of it
it was poly because the policy positions
I mean she wasn't she wasn't in a
variety way she wasn't a great candidate
but yeah I mean so for me the troubling
thing about Trump is partly to do with
this idea of the wall I mean in to the
extent that in some ways the cultural
politics of the right have crowded out
any policy positions that they that they
might have so not just of all the
regulation things another example
actually for the to appropriate new
regulation to get
scale-back so again it is kind of
gimmicky and there is this kind of
individualist libertarian conception we
don't want regulations and rules all
this kind of stuff and yet at the same
time
I mean it's gimmicky in the sense that
pretty soon they'll just figure out that
you just click three regulations
resonated what it won't work right
there's a map right here and on the
other hand I mean so it's not clear to
me though that that what libertarian the
classical liberals ought to be doing is
just a kind of a sort of whole scale
reduction in the state so so any you
know a lot of these you get these
reports X number of institutions have no
he's not making these appointments all
this kind of stuff these jobs aren't
going to have done it's not clear to me
that in the void left by whatever these
institutions were that whatever is going
to come in there is going to be
conducive individual liberty I mean
there's a sense in which when you know
when chaos is introduced when there's a
certain amount of disorder very rarely
is it that cut something like an ordered
Liberty as the result of that usually
it's whoever has the loudest voice twins
Ram and so I'm afraid at this point I'm
afraid of the loudest voices yeah
and I'm afraid of the ways in which this
kind of brute force approach to scaling
back government is going to allow those
louder voices to enter into the fray
what do you make for the argument that I
basically buy now I voted for Gary
Johnson very begrudging you were the one
I was the one guy I should be judged
accordingly by the way I'm not you know
and I need a perfectly nice guy and I
have had him on the show and I've
chatted with him privately and you know
a great guy to have dinner with but it
was a pretty pretty terrible candy but
what do you make for the argument that I
hear people say that Trump's win for
getting political philosophy forgetting
virtually everything you said here that
it just shook the system in a way that
no one else could have shook it so if
you believed that we had a real problem
here you know between a state that was
growing and NSA and taxes and whatever
foreign policy and all of this stuff
that just seems to get bigger and bigger
that he was the only sledgehammer
tonight I think there is some legitimacy
to that it doesn't mean that what's
going to come out on the other side is
going to be any better and you might be
right
that it's just going to bring on louder
voices and that this could be the
beginning of the
and of the Republic that although that
stuff uh but do you think that there's a
legitimacy to that line of thinking
though I know absolutely be clear I mean
it's you
now we're verging into the territory so
I mean I you know when I say I think I
think Trump is this I think Trump is
that I mean I want to emphasize that
this is what I think we're talking about
extremely complex systems I mean I think
it's very difficult anyone who says they
know what Trump is going to bring about
anyone says they know this was going to
happen that's what's gonna happen I mean
is is I you know either speaking from an
ideological position or it's just trying
to get clicks I mean so in other words I
don't in other words I have I have
relatively strong views about Trump and
yet I I still hold them weakly enough I
could be proven wrong yeah and this is
this is an interesting this is an
intriguing line of thought this idea
that that the American that American
government had has kind of taken on this
kind of autopilot it only grows it only
gets bigger it never ever recedes it
never scales back and that the only
thing that could ever bring about the
scaling back would be a kind of
catastrophic moment right so in Trump
with in this case would be that you are
the decent the sledgehammer yeah so I'm
sympathetic to that to that view and
there's and if you look at history right
I mean you can look at a number of
different events kind of great
historical you tend they tend to be Wars
right or whatever that on the one hand
they tend to be terrible when they're
happening and at the same time because
they kind of clear out space for
innovation to take place they kind of
clear out space for people to think
about the way they live in new ways all
those kind of stuff they can actually
end up having a long term beneficial
effect and so I'm skeptical that line of
thinking but I could I could definitely
see how it might how it might happen i
but i guess i worry about the short term
in other words i worry about a
large-scale war I mean I worry about
this idea of America being about walls I
worry about this kind of thing in the
short term and I worry that the that in
some sense we're producing a culture of
the right that isn't that it's going to
be hostile to individual delivery for a
very long time yeah I mean I worry about
all that stuff too and just as I said
all throughout the election his moral
compass I mean if this guy gets into a
queue
a missile crisis situation which way is
this whole thing going one other piece
is related to Trump what about the cult
of personality when it comes to all
these political philosophies that we're
talking about that here we have a guy
that it's really based on that and not
the political philosophy how should we
view that that it's very warily I mean
is it I mean if I saw do you have to say
their idea of a charismatic leader right
I mean is I mean most of the great
destructive movements of the 20th
century we're letting some at some level
by it by a great charismatic leader and
I want to be super clear I'm not saying
Trump is now and not saying compass is
stone or anything like like this but at
the same time I mean we can see this I
mean youyou I mean I'm not yeah I mean
presumably you have people on your
Facebook feed from you know that that
you watch Fox News or do whatever and
when you when you talk about any when
you go home when you talk to people and
there seems to be this sort of broad
willingness to listen the the media
itself they're reporting stories that I
have no reason to believe anymore that
the you know the kind of a mainstream
narratives that you got from the from
the media but from the universities that
I'm getting from Facebook that I'm
getting from all these sources I've no
reason to believe that these are true
anymore these have been in some sense
the curtains been pulled back you know
and I can see that there is some big II
the establishment right that has been
kind of feeding any line for years and
years and now for the first time right
Trump was the one who pulled the curtain
back and I can trust him he has access
to all these things after all he's
president I can trust him as an
authority not only as an authority in
terms of the sort of legal and political
authority that he's entrusted with as
president but I can trust him to shoot
straight in some sense and so once you
dig your heels in at that position
kind of close yourself epistemic ly off
from everything else that's bad I mean
there are very few examples historically
of where that is turned out well does
that show you how far we've come I guess
in the wrong direction in a weird way
because even right now as we're taping
this and this is going to go up in a
couple days but as we're taping this
this whole story about Susan Rice broke
and this unmasking of the names and all
that and immediately I saw on CNN they
were like three things immediately Don
Lemon who's been on the show as a friend
said you know we're not going to give
this any credence or something to that
effect Jim Sciuto and other CNN guy said
the same exact thing and then I think a
third CNN guy think maybe it was John
King saying this is all nonsense
something immensely quoting them but the
more they did that the more I was like
wait a minute there probably is
something here so that our trust in the
Fourth Estate now is so broken right
that that adds another piece into this
whole equation ya know it's it's it's a
it's a real mess in it in some sense it
I think it does it is a function of
technology in the sense that what
Twitter and what everyone having a
camera in their pockets whether they've
allowed us to do is to kind of peer
behind the curtain in a number of ways I
think you can look at something like
police brutality in a similar sort of
way so I mean we always kind of known
that particularly if you were black in
America right the interactions with the
police could go south pretty quickly but
now that everybody has a camera that's
always on in their pockets when we're
seeing things that we just cannot
believe and once you see the frequency
of these sorts of interactions once you
see this the I mean the sheer injustice
of how easy it is for you know for for
those for you know for police who do
this kind of thing but how easy is for
them to ticket to get off and all that
kind of stuff
he started wonder how widespread is this
likely how long has this been going on I
haven't known about this in other words
you begin to look at this thing right
you begin to look at American policing
didn't think this institution which even
ten years ago I had some modicum of
confidence and I thought was a
reasonable just institution now you
begin to think this is just this is a
House of Lies that I've been told my
entire life and weave in with
alternative media I mean we're told the
same thing so that you're on The Young
Turks at some points the other democracy
now I mean just YouTube the the way that
YouTube offers alternative narratives I
mean you know we've always had
alternative publications Mother Jones
and read and all this kind of stuff but
now we have a million of them now we
have entire channels which are dedicated
Fox News in a good example which which
conceive of themselves is providing an
alternative narrative to what's going on
and so suddenly right we're not going to
go back to or whatever Walter Cronkite
was right up it is I mean that was what
was in some sense true this was a kind
of a common epistemic aural that we all
lived in now we're all kind of fractured
and often our own community
that I think is a real problem and I
don't see what I mean for right now it
doesn't seem clear to me how that's
going to be pieced back together again
how long I'd be able to begin to start
agreeing on very basic facts was the
ones the president wiretapped
they're not right week it's almost as if
whatever happens over the course the
next six months will be unable to answer
that question in a way that's something
that's a basic empirical question right
and the hysteria machine and the outrage
regime adds to that so it's not just the
the technology of it but when Trump said
that thing when he tweeted that thing
about the wiretap I saw and I didn't
jump to comment immediately because I
was like let me see what happened now it
turns out that Obama probably did not
order it but if something did happen and
this is where then the truth becomes
subjective to everybody because if
you're only reading Media Matters and
Mother Jones or whatever you're gonna
get one thing is only reading Fox and
some other right with Breitbart or
whatever you're only going to get
something else and then we just send it
I mean in these publications no I'm
going to know what their job is right so
the thing comes out and they're their
job is spin right their job as they
listen this is clearly this is the
position that we must take and so we
must find the facts that conform to this
particular position and you know
whatever arguments whatever kind of back
flips we can perform to get into this I
mean all you know all the all the better
for us I mean it's just going to people
are going to keep clicking on articles
they're going to keep watching the news
and all this kind of stuff I mean it's
oh it is I mean it's so in other words
you're you're right in that on the one
hand it seems like our kind of share of
world has become fractured but the
people who are doing the fracture
they're very little incentive to stop in
fact they have every incentive to keep
fracturing yeah keep saying that it's us
and only us who can offer you the truth
about what happened oh no no no that's
who can offer you the analysis that's
going to that's going to cater to your
to what you want to hear anyway and yes
I mean that's ultimately I think that's
the other that's the other kind of part
of all this is that yeah we don't want
to hear like if you watch Fox News you
don't want to hear what they're saying
at Washington Post if you read the
Washington Post you don't want to hear
what they're saying approximating it's
uncomfortable for you
these are unpleasant experiences and if
we can you know ultimately I mean down
to the last click cater our online
experiences why would we introduce this
yeah and to our and this actually goes
all the way back guns for Melanie does
for mail describe this is it's a painful
experience you have people thankful this
green what people is painful coming to
the realization that you might be heaven
forbid long about something this is um
this is unpleasant yeah I'm glad you
brought it back that because so that
sort of sort of just to wrap everything
up here it's sort of a nice bow on all
this is there a moment do you think in
the last twenty years that we got much
worse at that because it does seem like
it's all bad worse and I don't know if
it's just the technology part I know
that's obviously a big piece but do you
think anything else may be culturally
happened or something in America is a
definitely do a 9/11 I mean I'm Brian
throwing things out there like do you
think there was something else to do for
the most part it would seem like a slow
creep right I mean these it seems like
it's all that the dripping when it's a
constant dripping drip drip drip every
morning you log on and just kind of
reinforces the the sort of positions
that you've already they've already
taken up and I mean it so that that's
interesting I mean for me the the moment
in which I guess the politics became
fractured in a way that I previously
wasn't aware of and I was just I was a
kid at the time but was probably during
the Clinton impeachment scandal I for a
variety of reasons but it was the way it
was the way that Gingrich was able to
organize resistance against Clinton for
the first time as it were it was they
adopted they adopted this this kind of
outsider pose I mean Newt Gingrich's
nill trying to describe himself as an
outsider as a drain aside I mean I mean
it's absolutely insane actually the guys
name is Newt he's a former Speaker of
the House and yet yeah drain the swamp
is his preferably that is sick but for
the first time I mean in that case it
there it seemed to me that there was
that these partisan affiliations that in
some sense the break was fundamental
that they were occupying different
spaces different worlds and that any
compromise between these two parties
would be viewed as as a betrayal by by
by the by loyalists now I mean it's very
very easy to say that no that's always
been the case politics has always been
that way look at Reagan look at this
look at that whatever
but for me anyway that was the
fundamental moment which I said these
two groups something-something is I
haven't covered up yeah in other but
again it was it was the cultural
politics that the right adopt that I
think in the late 90s that I think are
that proved particularly pernicious and
not as if cultural politics are only on
that we only have them we only have
right culpable both sides have these
things but it was that point and I think
the Internet does amplify this to a
certain extent we're not interested in
policies but we aren't written symbols
emerges in symbols with cultural cachet
and when we talk politics now we talk in
terms of of symbol I mean for example i
kk US soldier right so if you're if you
you know if you're on the right you're
tend to refer to them as troops i
support our troops right i mean for
whatever reason we've just sort of
gravitated towards this word troop you
just don't hear the term troops as often
I think in on somewhere like Mother
Jones they tend to raise soldiers in
some sense for whatever reason I mean
these it seems that you would think
that's different Imperial death soldiers
anything case with a relative that's
right I mean you think that the
difference would be utterly and not with
I mean there are literally synonyms yeah
and yet for whatever reason they when
you hear the word troop a different kind
of cultural image comes to mind a
different kind of symbol comes to mind
verses when you hear the word soldier
and I no idea why that's the case but
we've always almost as if we begun
speaking different languages depending
on on which cultural group we feel like
we belong to yeah alright so final
question to wrap this all up and I mean
we could do we could do this all right I
got two more interviews so for all the
people that hear you that hear these
ideas of classical liberalism I'm
thrilled that for the little bit that
I've been doing the show these last
couple years I feel like the phrase
classical liberalism
has come out a little bit you hear it
now in mainstream it's nice it's coming
around so for the people that want
conversation that want to not just
impune their intellectual opponents and
that actually want conversation all that
stuff what's the best method you're
around a lot of young people you're
teaching this stuff ways just because
that I get tons of email about this what
do I do if I want to be in the
conversation and not smeared and
maligned and all that lined up what's
the best way to march forward but that's
interesting actually and just just based
on the conversation that we've had
I mean I would some sense to stay off of
social media second I mean at some level
I mean because at some level classical
liberalism is it's a it's a difficult
doctrine as an individual I think I mean
it says listen at some level you are
responsible for your own views at some
level you're responsible for exercising
individual judgment you aren't going to
be just sort of spoon-fed a series of
ideological signifiers that you can
latch on to whenever you need them
you're going to have to adjudicate
you're going have to read you have to
think you're going to have to be the
kind of person who's capable of being
responsible enough to be free and so I
would say you know ya argue all you want
to debate all you want to discuss how
you want to but I would I would do it in
a way I would do it in good faith I
would assume that whoever it is that
you're talking to that they have
something to offer that they're capable
of changing their minds that they're
arguing with you in good faith right
that they aren't merely running through
a script of views that they already hold
or something like that
and that you assume the same position
you say I I could be wrong but the sort
of thing I haven't read everything I
haven't you know I there are limits to
my own understanding and I'm willing to
explore those limits so the burdens on a
burden we got we got the work cut out
for us right that's what I mean that's
what freedom at some level is it's about
I mean is that you as an individual are
responsible for making your own way no I
think that's a fitting ending to this
conversation for more on professor
Turner check out learn liberty org slash
speakers slash Brandon - Turner
[Music]
you
[Music]